is where things are going to get a
little weird I love it when things are
weird
good to know that nothing we've talked
about so far has been weird yeah okay
[Music]
hey crazies welcome to another episode
of wife reacts this is my wife awkward M
hello this video is going to be an
overview of something we call Quantum
field Theory or qft for short basically
it's what is the nature of matter why
did we invent Quantum Fields you know
what was the motivation behind it that
that sort of thing
so I guess let's start with uh what
exactly do you know about Quantum field
Theory I was afraid you were going to
ask me this question uh almost nothing
if it has to do with Quantum particles
I'm gonna go out on a limb here where
they come from where they go if I had to
guess
but I really don't know so we're
starting from a pretty basic
basic set of knowledge here right yes
what is this it's a ball it's a ball so
just like anything else this ball is
made of materials which are then made of
molecules which are then made of atoms
which are then made of subatomic
particles we can just sort of break this
down right it's a method we call
reductionism we reduce it into its
fundamental parts
now if we reduce everything in the
universe into its fundamental or
Elementary Parts okay what we get is a
set of Elementary particles sure this is
all of the fundamental or Elementary
particles that we are aware of yep and
it's a pretty small list technically
every single one of these has a
anti-particle most of the things that we
experience we we interact with on a
daily basis us all the objects around us
and so on with very very few exceptions
are made of three of these particles the
up Quark the down quark and the electron
sure that's it yeah and those things
tend to interact with each other via
photons those are sort of the four
Elementary particles that we ever
interact with light as we saw from the
particle chart is made of photons these
particles yes what other way do we model
photons as what other way do we model
light as I should say and if you go all
the way back to yeah we model it as
waves right so an electromagnetic wave
is a disturbance in something we call
the electromagnetic field and that looks
something like this yes I am familiar
with this animation right so an oldie
but a good it only but a goodie this is
one of my faves in this animation you've
essentially got all these points across
space and each point has a value
attached to some kind of quantity in
this case vectors but there's a quantity
attached to every point in space and
that's what we refer to as feel that's
what a field is sure what we did back in
the the late 1800s as we modeled light
as a disturbance in that field
we do this with lots of things it's not
just with electromagnetism we can do it
with the pressure in a water tank right
we can assign a pressure value to every
single point inside the tank we can do
it with temperature we can do it with
temperature absolutely when we set up
these values as a field it opens up an
entire division of mathematics that we
can use on it yeah okay
to what I've always wanted it's a really
big deal we can calculate things like
divergences and curls and gradients and
so if we can set up a scenario as a
field it's very useful it's a very
useful tool doesn't mean that the field
is something that exists it's just a
collection of numbers okay but it's a
very powerful tool sure the particle
concept of a photon rolled around in
like the early 1900s we started to think
that oh well maybe everything is a
particle and it only looks like it's a
disturbance in a field as we leaned into
the particle model we started to run
into problems right we started to run
into not being able to incorporate
relativity and having to put patches on
to explain the hydrogen atom and people
started to ask the question well like
what if particles aren't how matter
Works what if particles are the illusion
and they're actually waves and they're
actually
disturbances disturbances we say waves
but waves is kind of it can be
misleading if you're not familiar with
the concept already do we say waves like
we say spin no it's not that bad okay
but if you want to call any disturbance
in some medium a wave sure but I think
it might give someone who isn't
necessarily familiar with physics the
wrong impression okay see because like
okay
this is a good question this is a great
question when you hear the word wave you
probably think of you know like a full
wave maybe than the surface of some
water or something a wave on a string
maybe but in physics we tend to call any
disturbance in uh some substance or
medium or whatever a wave so even if
it's like boom and it's a pulse that's
traveling along a string that's still
considered a wave it's still described
by the same mathematics I'm comfortable
with that yeah that's okay it's still
real right and so you gotta kind of be a
little more vague just because it's not
repeating doesn't mean that a wave does
not exist right it's still the same it's
still the same phenomenon even if it's
one right
I'm gonna stop beating around the bush
and we're going to talk about exactly
what a Quantum field is yes let's Okay
we already saw the electromagnetic field
where there was this you know vector or
Arrow attached to every point in space
what if particles are the illusion and
matter behaves as disturbances and
Fields instead okay
rather than some value of some
measurement being attached to every
point in space it was essentially
existence attached to every point in
space existence existence of what we
would perceive as a particle any
particle any elementary particle yes
okay yeah it's not like only electrons
are found in the electron field and only
of quarks of quarks yes are found in the
up Quark field that's that's how it is
that is how it is yes they each get
their own field okay but an up Quark in
an anti-up Quark are in the same field
an electron and an anti-electron are in
the same field also known as a posteron
correct okay every point in space has an
existence value essentially and you can
see that each of those points are
wiggling every point is wiggling sure
that's sort of the quantum uncertainty
going on here right if there's a large
enough disturbance a full disturbance in
this field we perceive that disturbance
as a particle okay so if there's a
disturbance in the electron field it
might be an electron or a positron
depending on what the disturbance looks
like okay if is a disturbance in the
photon field then what we're going to
see is a photon sure we're going to
observe that as a photon even though the
photon isn't really there there's no
really particle there it's just a
disturbance in a field is there an
anti-photon yes but the anti-photon is
just a photon
photons are wild yeah okay it is its own
anti-particle
but yes every particle has an
anti-particle it just might be itself
I'm not here for that
but okay
with this graph
s that it makes space look like it's
discrete like there are these little
pieces and they have size right which is
not really how it works it's kind of
misrepresenting it a little bit but when
I made this graphic like what five years
ago I didn't really have the animation
skill to do better to do better right
but now a real Quantum field is
continuous there would be a disturbance
at an individual point in a continuous
space okay rather than a box being up
higher than the rest of the boxes what
you see is a spike in a surface which
might be called a wave if you will yes
we would treat this Spike that moves
around as a wave pulse it's just a
disturbance in the electron field for
example in this case electric charge is
represented by color red for positive
and purple for negative and Quantum spin
orientation is represented by the
vertical Direction up for a spin up and
down for spin down it's a representation
that it's not really going up and down
these fields are actually 3 dimensional
but if I showed you a three-dimensional
version of this your eyes and brain
would just be overwhelmed and it
wouldn't be useful sure something we do
in physics is we suppress dimensions in
order to make sense of things this is
very common I'm comfortable with that
honestly in this case three-dimensional
space has been compressed into a
two-dimensional plane and we're using
that Dimension we suppressed as a way to
show other information like Quantum spin
for example and it's not like the fields
occupy different places in space they
all occupy all space correct yes they're
all like coexisting they all coexist and
overlap each other right which allows
particle interactions to happen because
then energy can be exchanged between
Fields if you have an electron and a
positron come together at the same spot
what you get is antimatter Annihilation
ah okay which is how that works sure
they just cancel each other they just
cancel each other out because they have
opposite values and it essentially turns
the quantum field to a zero value or
what we would call the vacuum state of
the field and by doing that by by
assigning existence to every point in
space you're essentially assigning all
possible properties for those particles
for those things we perceive as
particles into that spot all the
information is there it has to be right
sure because existence is there and so
this is kind of what separates a Quantum
field from a regular old field like the
electromagnetic field poor
electromagnetic fields an old regular
field there's some debate over whether
or not these Quantum Fields actually
exist but the usefulness and accuracy of
the model was kind of hard to argue with
does anything actually exist I mean like
I mean we know light exists and we know
matter definitely exists which is the
point to this video we're going to come
back to that but matter definitely
exists it is not an illusion we try to
represent it in different ways depending
on what we need to predict
1949 rolls around
and this one guy famous guy named
Richard Feynman enters the scene for a
while we have been doing these Quantum
field calculations and they're real
nasty We're not gonna do any today it's
not that's not what this video is about
so he came up with something that we now
call Feynman diagrams that's what it is
I'm like I'm sure I've heard you talk
about this before okay right but they're
basically space-time diagrams which I've
done a ton of videos about most of the
information from those videos you don't
actually need to understand this you
just need to understand that like time
is on the picture he didn't necessarily
in this paper come up with a way to
represent all types of particles in it
and one of these diagrams he didn't even
know about quarks sure at the time
nobody did but he did come up with a way
for things like electrons and positrons
to interact with photons which is what
we've been talking about this entire
video If particles come together and
interact we want to be able to represent
that and be able to calculate what's
going to happen with Quantum Fields you
know how are things going to go in and
how are things going to go out straight
up is time is the time axis okay and so
as these two particles come together
they do some kind of interaction and
then particles then come out and we want
to be able to predict exactly how this
is going to take place we can see that
in we can see the out like what happened
inside of this black box this unknown
area is it important that the lines are
angled yeah because they're they're the
particles are coming together gotcha
horizontal of space okay bring it
together and then going apart yes gotcha
okay so these particles somehow
interacted maybe this was like two
electrons coming together and then
repelling each other for a while we
would go through start from like
fundamental principles and we would go
through all the nasty Quantum field
Theory calculations and figure out
what's going to happen it was so
absurdly difficult the jiggly spots is
the vacuum state of the quantum field
what if we can pretend that those
wiggles and jiggles are particles
because if they're not necessarily zero
but they're not like a whole occupation
of a spot they're not so they're not
actual particles but maybe we can
pretend they're particles something that
we now call virtual particles they're
not actually particles but we can
pretend that they are if we do that then
we can start to simplify the math a
little bit maybe when the two electrons
come together a photon bounces between
them and allows them to repel they're
they're maybe they're interacting with
this Photon this photon is not a real
Photon it's inside that black box oh the
only actual particles here are the two
electrons coming in and going out okay
the problem is this box is unknown and
there are other possibilities other ways
that these part these electrons can
interact with each other via these
virtual particles okay we can imagine a
more complicated scenario maybe they
exchange two photons two virtual photons
they're always virtual because it's in
the box if it's in the black box it's
virtual okay unless it went in or came
out it's not a real particle and also
maybe they exchanged two photons or
maybe a photon jumped out of one and
jumped back in before they exchanged a
photon or you know maybe they they went
to exchange a photon but that Photon
decayed into an electron positron pair
before becoming a photon again before
hitting the other electron so all of
these different scenarios are possible
scenarios okay and because the boxes are
known and these are virtual particles we
need a way to account for all of them
what it did was it took this huge nasty
calculation that could be really
cumbersome and almost impossible
sometimes and it turned it into a bunch
of little calculations that are fairly
calculable okay and then all you got to
do is add the results together how many
different options are in the Box an
infinite number yeah so it doesn't feel
doable right when you have to calculate
every one of them that's that's a great
question actually as it turns out
something that Feynman discovered while
he was playing around with this he was
like well I mean I don't have to
calculate all of them it just seems like
a lot you know so what he did was he
really realize that as he calculated
them the more complicated they were the
smaller of a contribution it made to the
calculation each of these diagrams has a
number of these dots that we refer to as
vertexes or vertices okay the number of
vertices is a way to determine how much
of a contribution that scenario is going
to make
some point you can just stop because the
the the terms aren't making any
contributions contributions to your
calculation it's going to be negligible
right you're going to be close enough
something you might have noticed in
those diagrams is that there's really
only one type of vertex every single one
of these vertexes has two straight lines
at a wiggly line that that's that's all
that can exist in what we call Quantum
electrodynamics which is a type of
quantum field theory is where things are
going to get a little weird
oh
excellent I love it when things are
weird
good to know that nothing we've talked
about so far has been weird yeah okay
what you've got here is you've got an
electron coming in and here's the weird
part this is a positron coming in even
though the arrow points the wrong way
that's what tells us it's a positron
you have a question
how do you know if you're dealing with
an electron or a positron via the
diagram if it looks exactly the same
because in a Feynman diagram we
represent antimatter as matter going
backward in time uh okay and so any
arrows that point backward in time are
anti-particles why do we represent it
that way because it makes the math work
out it's a time they're not yeah and not
even Feynman thought that he didn't
actually see he he made a point to say
like I don't actually think
anti-particles are are particles going
backward in time that's ridiculous I
feel like he's taking a lot of Liberties
yeah with like the virtual particles and
the backwards in time now and it's
making me feel like it is less reputable
he viewed this as just a tool for
solving Quantum field Theory problems he
didn't view this as reality how do you
know if the answer to your problem is
correct or not because you can check it
how experimentally ah okay we've seen
that this gives us answers that match
reality okay I'm more comfortable with
it then okay okay so here's one scenario
you've got an electron and a positron
coming together annihilating and making
a photon okay okay does that make sense
yes okay so they annihilate each other
they go to zero but the energy has to go
somewhere and so it gets kind of shunted
into the photon field but if I turn this
now we've got an electron coming in an
electron going out and Photon going out
so now we have enough we have an
electron emitting a photon and changing
direction gotcha it's a y yeah okay
we have an electron absorbing a photon
and then changing direction but still an
electron but still an electron both the
arrows are pointed up in time yep what
do we have here a photon coming in and
dividing into an electron and a positron
exactly yeah see see this is huh this is
how you read these diagrams so once you
know the rules you can kind of figure it
out right and so you just keep going so
here we have a similar scenario that we
had before but it's a positron this time
positron comes in absorbs a photon and
changes Direction okay here we've got a
positron that emits a photon and changes
Direction it's no oh okay and then we're
back to the beginning so like those are
the scenarios those are the only
scenarios that can happen in what we
call Quantum electrodynamics okay does
that make sense and then you can have
variations of this that get more
complicated right you can just combine a
bunch of these together and how many of
these you combine together determines
how big of a contribution it makes okay
purpose of quantum field Theory
it is to predict how these particles
will interact it's about particle
interactions if there are no particle
interactions Quantum field theory is
kind of useless sure and so what the
standard model tells us is that
different particles different fields
interact in different ways
sense and we we do the calculations
using things like Feynman diagrams okay
we know this racquetball exists we know
that it's made up of fundamental Parts
Elementary parts that interact and we
can we know what those interactions look
like this Elementary Parts might be
particles they might be ways they might
be disturbances in fields but at the end
of the day they are real things
we're just debating over what kind of
real thing they are matter does exist it
just wasn't what we originally thought
it was welcome to science yeah and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy
the Multiverse isn't scientific why are
you even talking about it it may not be
testable so we can't call it a
scientific fact but it's still
scientific it's based on time-tested
models and it's important to explore the
extremes of our models that's where all
the theoretical Discovery happens anyway
thanks for watching